[Musique]
vous étiez nominé aux césars weegee
dernier et qu'est ce qui se passe
lorsqu'on ouvre l'enveloppent on se dit
ça y est je vais la voir et puis quand
le nombre sort pas il ya une déception
comme ans qu'on vit cela n'y avait pas
de déception parce que je le savais
avant ah oui parce que j'avais entendu
des bruits de couloir et caetera et puis
que
et puis que non mais en fin de compte je
suis très heureuse de ne pas l'avoir
c'est vraiment bizarre sur le moment
j'étais un peu gêné parce que je me suis
dit c'est quand même c'est quand même
dur de le donner à celle qui a les plus
gros seins quoi parce que c'était
vraiment ça en plus ça sentait c'était
tellement évident
ah non mais c'est ignoble j'ai trouvé ça
c est en fin de compte je me suis dis
bah tant mieux parce que comme ça au
moins ça veut dire que ça veut dire que
je suis pas je suis pas un produit qu'on
essaye de monter en épingle comme ça en
deux trois mois est ce que c'est ce qui
s'est passé pour elle et que je suis je
suis en fait je suis plus une comédienne
qu'une savonnette ouais je suis très
fier ce qu'il a déjà eue la file aux
gros seins c'est qui je dis pas de nom
lorsque je me rappelle plus moi j'ai
oublié les césar
non non je dis pas de nom je veux rien
non mais non je me donne bien votre
franchise non mais en fait quand je suis
assez heureuse puisque non c'est vrai
que non c'est ça me plaît cette idée de
ne pas l'avoir eu et c'est la deuxième
fois en plus que j'étais nominé donc ça
veut dire que quelque part je suis quand
même aimé dans ce métier mais que je
suis pas je suis pas un phénomène de
mode donc ça me fait plaisir vous allez
durée on va vous retrouver samedi avec
nous on sera encore en direct du
festival du court métrage de brest car
vous allez là-bas vous serez membre du
jury donc on va vous retrouver les
téléspecteurs vont pouvoir vous
retrouver puis le public de braise à
pouvoir aussi venir dialoguer avec nous
avec julie delpy là vous avez senti sa
sensibilité voilà si vous avez compris
sous les réussir dans le métier aussi
travailler votre prêtrise d'un des
hommes
merci violi la pub est ainsi plus la
météo
[Musique]